poor Troy on the bone secret is now to
take that beautiful eye of meat off the
bone and cut eight incredible steaks
first off it's a t-shaped bone there
it's going through is the blade there's
the base that there creates the most
amazing cracking make sure you stabilize
again boning knife super sharp really
important will slice through there come
down off the back slice through and
start to open up cutting in it's a
little Ridge there come over the ridge
careful not to slice through that eye
fingers here it's pulling back once I
start pulling back and I feel the lift
of the loin of pork come back down in
toward the bone turn the knife up in to
the eye of the meat you're gonna destroy
it firmly hold and slice down as you
slice peel back I want to see those ribs
nice and clean once we get there they
said bendy flexible knife and it's done
purposely for slicing follow the shape
pull back look at where I am check what
you're doing
stay accurate stay close to the bone off
now
loin bone from there you can see the eye
the skin we turn it over flat side down
come into the fat and we just pierce in
there and then thumb inside Nick a
little bit of fat through and literally
pull off
now look at the eye remove the eye that
is the beautiful nut of meat that gets
crispy there's your crackling from there
it's silver skin of fat and I'll go
through the eye of the meat but I want
to trim this up pork is very lean so you
have to leave a little cap of fat on
there trim and then size up we want four
amazing cuts big knife for the weight so
it's four so lightly mark there there
and there
pushing with this hand to keep that last
slice super straight roll it up let the
knife do the work slice down off one
beautiful going to pork grip use five
fingers grip stop the wobbling on hand
on top there the knife do the work too
final size it up let the knife do the
work open up the fingers there come down
straight open one two three four
stunning loin chops off the bone
great sear and literally six seven
minutes three minutes on each side let
it rest
you've got pork at its best